dans les rues de Kerson les Ukrainiens à
l'oeuvre dans ce qu'ils ont appris à
maîtriser la débrouille et la solidarité
radeau de fortune barque paddle camion
spécialisé face à la montée des eaux une
urgence évacuée ceux qui sont prises au
piège
cette femme arrive pieds nus avec juste
quelques affaires
vous habitez où
tonton
on est monté à l'étage les sauveteurs
qui sont venus avaient de l'eau jusque
là
on a passé la nuit au troisième étage
parce que l'eau avait atteint le
deuxième étage
ce matin pas de tir d'artillerie dans
cette ville toujours au centre des
combats
on a trois bateaux alors c'est moi qui
vous donne les adresses d'accord il faut
profiter de la calmis les bateaux
gonflables arrivent de tout le pays
mobilisation la rage au ventre pour ses
habitants qui ont déjà dû composer avec
l'occupant russe pendant 8 mois
je suis en colère tout le monde lutte à
cause de ces gens qui voulaient
soi-disant nous sauver
dans un petit coin Valentina 90 ans
attend depuis hier elle a été évacuée
mais n'a pas de nouvelles de son chien
son seul compagnon elle ne veut pas
bouger
mon chien est tout seul là-bas il doit
avoir peur le pauvre
je veux juste la paix pour tout le monde
moi
ces rues nous les avons arpentées des
dizaines de fois depuis plusieurs mois
aujourd'hui certains quartiers de Kerson
sont méconnaissables le pic de la montée
des eaux devrait être atteint dans les
prochaines heures